look i gotta ask you this because you
know not an interview goes by where i
don't ask you about the m word and i
have to
for the navy and for the sake and don't
get mad at me girl
don't give me nagging that i can't i
can't get mad it's rachel you know
bree girl we are reunited i'm so happy
to see your face it's so good to see
you i'm really happy to see you too no
more red carpet these days but i get to
see a little bit
i have you been i've been hanging in
there but more importantly how have you
been
how have you been spending your time
these days i mean obviously you've been
working on an amazing skincare line
but what else has rihanna been doing
um you know i really thought that
this quarantine era would seem like you
know when
snow days when school are out for me
that's hurricane days and barbados when
you get to stay home for a few days and
it's like wow we don't have to go
anywhere that's great
but i've been more busy in quarantine
than ever before
and i have been
uh just preparing for this launch
this has been it's like a newborn so you
just you have to
nourish it and be hands on and i've been
really excited so it's it's time now and
i can't believe it happened that quickly
we've been working on it
for years so it feels like it's been
we've been waiting and waiting
congrats on the skin care line girl
because i feel like
now could not be a better time for a
skin inclusive line to really launch
i feel like you have been at the
forefront of this movement so
how does it feel to be a pioneer of an
inclusivity
movement thank you so much
um being inclusive for me always came
second nature um growing up in my
household i've always looked
up to my mom as like my beauty
inspiration
i wanted to do everything that she did
but
it didn't come as like a surprise or
like we needed to crack the code on
makeup to me when i was making
foundation
including shade ranges
like hers because i've always seen that
so i've applied that to everything that
i've done
because i see how women become so
emotionally
invested and they feel represented they
feel like they can see
themselves on the shelves and the
campaigns and
and even in sizes in my
in my lingerie line so with skin care we
we're going to do the same thing we want
these these products to work for all
skin types
and of course all skin tones yeah it's a
beautiful thing
you know and you're thinking that with
the skincare line it's awesome but
also calling this a new culture of skin
care how so what does that mean to you
uh skin care this is a newborn
baby in the skin care industry and so
i am going to approach it with a new
eye my eye but also i want these things
to be different from everything that's
on the market i want it to be simple
i want it to be accessible but still
with the high level of ingredients
that some of these other brands do but
they're so
expensive and i realized that you can
actually
make the best product and it does not
have to be inaccessible
and to start off with a million things
it kind of confuses the consumer you
give them what they need at first
three simple steps and from there we
take them on a journey throughout their
skincare
i love it girl you you and i both know
you walk down the aisle and you're like
oh my gosh
yeah i don't know which one is for me i
know
so i wanted to i wanted to simplify that
for
for our consumers well thank goodness i
love it and it's eco-friendly
thank you that's awesome girl you're
just hitting it on all cylinders right
now
but i was so interested in hearing and
reading that
your journey with skin care like so many
of us started as a teen but you tried to
probably
like discolor your skin so what happened
on that front
i mean you always you start off with
acne right
and then you want to go into acne
treatments and
i was just starting my career as a
teenager when i was going through these
breakouts
and so i went to like what i thought was
like the best of the best
um doctors to take care of my skin
and it ended up being too harsh for my
skin
it wasn't for my skin type or my skin
tone
it bleached me it blotched my skin up in
patches
and then that took years to even get
back but then
there's hyperpigmentation then there's
i'm 32
you know and look at there's so many
different levels
of the journey that it's complicated
yeah but you you go through this journey
and
i had to take all of that into account
when making
this line and starting it because i
wanted everyone to be a part of it and
not feel like
might not work for me or it's too harsh
for me i don't like i don't like
anything that's harsh
yeah no and i'm so glad that we have
these three simple steps to go
through with you to go on the skin care
journey and i love seeing the campaign
and honey i noticed that asap rocky was
making a debut in your campaign and
looking
very fine in the process how did he get
in the campaign well he's
to me in in the industry he's one of the
guys that like
everybody loves their skin i mean i've
always wanted to know
how the heck do you have better skin
like
half these girls i mean like what what
do you do
but i wanted men to be represented
because this skincare line is gender
neutral i want it to be for everyone
and so you don't men get scared
to use skincare they think it's like a
feminine thing they think it's just for
girls and
i don't i don't like that idea because
we all have skin we all wear skin
and so i needed that male representation
in the campaign
so rocky and nancy nazax
sorry not nice nasty i'm not lex
i can't call him nas for short there's
already a
a little nasdaq yeah exactly we wanted
that male representation so
men knew that it was okay it's so good i
can't wait to pass this along to my now
fiance
so he's gonna have to oh congrats girl
girl what is this a quarantine a
quarantine
engagement i know i'll have to send you
a wedding invite girlfriend
thanks thanks i'll interview you
look i gotta ask you this because you
know not an interview goes by where i
don't ask you about the m word and i
have to
for the navy and for the sake and don't
get mad at me girl
don't give me that i'm not getting that
i can't i can't get mad it's rachel you
know
but i gotta ask you got a lot of time in
quarantine i know bendy skin it's now
launched it's out there
are you flexing your music chops girl
are you working on some music while
we're all on lockdown
i am always working on music
i'm always working on music and when i'm
ready
to put it out in the way that i feel fit
it's gonna come out and you're not gonna
be disappointed when it happens
it's gonna be worth it i'm not just
gonna put it out just because
people are waiting like it's taking this
long i'm gonna make it
worth it i love it i and we can't wait
for it but i had to ask you
you know it's okay i know they they
probably come for you if you didn't ask
oh you know what when they had the the
rumor mill was going a couple days ago
about you and eminem collaborating it
was like no guys it was just a throwback
reminiscing about your your reunions and
stuff oh wow
but girl i gotta say this year has been
huge for you because you celebrated
the 15th anniversary of honda replay
you've got the 10th anniversary of
um what's my name and also love the way
you like
i mean when you think about those songs
what comes to mind
when you think i mean 10-year 15-year
anniversary of these things
what comes to mind with those songs
i'm 10 years older i'm 15 years older
like i thought that was just like a few
few years ago now it's like
a decade plus that is what i think about
but i'm also really grateful to still be
here and and being able to expand into
other ventures and i'm
grateful it's it's been fun i can't even
complain
uh well ray we can never complain
chatting with you and of course all the
great work that you're doing for
foundation
thank you you are making a difference
during covid19
thank you so much congrats on the launch
and i look forward to chatting with you
out of this lockdown i know i can't wait
i appreciate you rachel oh thank you i
appreciate you too darling take care
[Music]
okay